marcus morris will man the middle how
about with kawhi leonard only three
field goal attempts
and two points here and great defense
there by cousins
morris just takes it away runs the floor
and yeah
you're right what a play demarcus
cousins
in there and making things happen again
did not see the floor in the first round
and now taron lou
is making changes yeah and then running
the floor after the great defensive
effort and able to take
the hit and get the finish and that was
terrific
hands there defensively by cousins and
then as you mentioned running that floor
and that's what we talk about can you
convert off the good defense in
transition
that was a great example of it there by
the top
well who really did outstanding work in
that dallas series
the team never lost hope down 0-2 down
3-2 having to go to dallas to keep the
series alive and then win a game seven
and he pushed all the right buttons that
shot doesn't go
the missed by ingles and the clear by
cousins
rondo hits the deck cousins nabs it
is good